hello everyone uh today i'm going to be
talking about a complete linear
programming hierarchy for linear codes
so let me start by briefly reviewing uh
some basics of coding theory so in
coding theory we are particularly
interested
with the following problem we want to
send a message through some some channel
that possibly has some noise and might
corrupt our message
and the idea is very simple
instead of using all possible bits for
my message i'm going to restrict my
attention to some subsets of all
possible uh strings of in inlay and
length strings bits and this is called a
code so it's a subset of all possible
strings and we are mainly interested in
two quantities of these codes
the first is the rate which is very
natural is it's measuring how much
information i have per bit so that's
just the log base two of the size of the
code divided by n
and the second is the distance of the
code which is the just the minimum
distance of any two different code words
in my code and distance here is the
hamming distance so it's the number of
bits that they differ
now uh distance here is kind of
measuring the robustness of the code uh
through to corruption because if i
receive some code word and i know that
at most
less than
distance over two bits got corrupted
then i can just look at the nearest code
word that is valid and i would know that
that was the correct code word that that
was sent to me so of course here i'm
saying you could just look at the
nearest one whether you can do this
algorithmically fast or not is a very
interesting problem in its own right but
here we're going to just be concentrated
on the theoretical part of whether this
is how large can the code be
while uh i still have some robustness so
in a very simple question how large can
the rate be
while the distance is still large and
this boils down to these two quantities
right so a2 nd uh is just measuring the
size of the best best possible code of
distance at least d and r2 delta here is
the best asymptotic asymptotic rate of
of
of a code that has distance at least
delta n
and
as you might expect from the title of
the talk oh i should say that our regime
we are particularly interested in the
regime where d is delta times n for some
constant delta that's between zero and
one half because above one half the
codes that survive are very tiny so so
it's a linear distance
now
from the title of our talk you might
expect that we are particularly
interested in linear codes and these are
just linear subspaces of this this
finite vector space and in this case the
distance there's a much easier way of
computing the distance which is just the
minimum hemi weight of a non-zero code
word so so it's just the number of bits
that are are non-zero
okay so
what do we know what are the classic
results of the literature so in the 50s
gilbert showed that random codes are
pretty good so if you
insert code code words in into your code
with a certain probability and you play
around with the parameters you can see
that you can attain uh distance uh delta
times n
with the code that has rate roughly 1
minus entropy of delta uh so entropy
here the binary entropy
a little bit later version will notice
that you can also do this with linear
codes or random linear codes so if you
pick uniformly at random generating
matrix for a linear code and you adjust
the dimensions appropriately you're
going to get a linear code with a
relative distance delta that has rate 1
minus entropy of delta
now on the other side of the bounds the
best upper bound that we have at least
asymptotically is called the lp bone uh
due to necklace
uh
run c and welch and it gives gives this
strange function so it's entropy of one
half minus square root of delta one
minus delta and just so that we have
some idea of how these these uh
quantities look like uh there's a graph
here so this this purple line is the gv
bound so below this we know that codes
exist with these this this choice of
distance and rate and this green line
here uh is the mrrw bound or the lp
bound if you will which means that above
this line nothing actually exists with
this with this distance and rate and in
between we don't really know so the
question is how do what what happens in
between these two curves
and we are particularly interested in in
this uh side of the of this graph uh so
delta is one half minus epsilon for some
very small constant epsilon and in this
case uh this is roughly what these two
bonds look like so the gv bound looks
like epsilon squared and the mrrw bound
looks like epsilon square log one over
epsilon so if you believe that the gv
bound is the correct one which there are
many people that do believe that that is
the correct one you need to find a way
of removing this log one over excellent
term
okay so let me dive a little bit deeper
into the lp bound because our hierarchy
is actually going to be a generalization
of that
so
the lp bond is based is part of a family
of bonds known as convex
optimization bonds so the idea of these
kinds of bonds is you come up with a
convex optimization problem such that
each code gives a feasible solution to
this problem and it's typically a
maximization problem so this means that
if you look at the optimum value of this
problem it's going to be an upper bound
for the size of the code
so here's what the the lp bond comes
from it comes from the del certain
linear program which is this linear
program here
and the intended solution or the
solution that comes from codes
is what is sometimes called
the weight profile of the code or the
distance profile of the code which is
this quantity here so if you're going to
evaluate that i you're going to look at
how many pairs of code words are a
distance i and you divide that number by
the size of the code so let's just check
that
some of these constraints are satisfied
so for instance a0 is equal to 1 this is
very easy because for them to have
distance 0 it needs to be of the form xx
so you have something like size of the
whole divided by size of the code gives
you 1.
uh a i is equal to 0 for i between 1 and
d minus 1. that's also easy because our
code is assumed to have distance at
least d so so no no no pair of code
words can have distance between one and
d minus one now you have these mac
winnings inequalities which i'm not
going to cover now but i'm going to
cover later and
the final one is also trivial because
because these things are counting things
it's certainly non-negative numbers and
finally notice that the objective value
here when you sum all these quantities
uh this corresponds to dropping this
this constraint here so you get
something like size of the code squared
divided by size of the quotes so the the
final value is size of the code so this
means that the optimum value of this
linear program is certainly an upper
bound for the size of the best possible
code of distance at least
now uh
what i want you to pay attention to is
that this kind of uh
this linear program is particularly
studying interaction between two points
right you're looking at two code words
looking at their distance and then
counting how many guys have a certain
distance right
and it's very natural because you know
the the distance itself of the code is
based off based off of uh
interaction between two points but you
could ask whether
studying interaction between more points
could have more information that the
convex optimization problem could use to
drive down the the optimum value and
indeed people have studied that so
shriver
came up with a semi-definite program
that was studying three-point
interactions and it turns out that it's
slightly better than the dos rtlp uh
by slightly here i mean that you can run
some numeric values and you can see that
it's actually better from the australp
but we don't know if it actually
improves the lp boundary symbolically
because nobody was able to analyze it
yet
uh later on uh gishwhed without shriver
again uh also did a four-point
interaction sdp
and that that prompts the question can
you do an arbitrary number of points
like interaction between an arbitrary
number of points and indeed you can
people have done this but before i get
into that let me uh briefly remind a
couple of concepts of convex
optimization
namely
notice that
if you
think about it for a second
the
problem of quotes can be stated in the
language of graph theory because you can
just think that you have a graph
such that the vertex sets are all
possible code words and you put an edge
every time two code words have distance
less than b
then it's very easy to see that a code
of distance at least e is nothing more
than an independent set in this graph so
you can use any kind of of bonds that is
provided by convex optimization for the
independence
set and
for this particular graph
one that's going to be very important
for us is uh the lowest theta prime
function
which is this particular semi-definite
program now it's not that important uh
what this looks like uh what is more
important is that there's a result by
schreiber that says that
the del certainlp is actually equivalent
to this theta prime function
namely uh if you look at this graph it
actually has a lot of symmetries
for example uh
if you or at least if you look at this
program
you have a translation symmetry there is
if you translate both of the coordinates
by the same uh code word you're gonna
see that this preserves uh
the feasibility of the solution and
another kind of symmetry that you have
is permutation of bits so you have in
bits if you swap around the bits
then of course it's a this is completely
symmetric because at the end of the day
the distance only counts how many of
them are non-zero or are different so
you have the symmetry on the problem so
this means that you could factor out the
symmetry out of the theta prime and once
you do that it's it's very nice because
you now consider solutions that are
symmetric under this action and it turns
out that
these such matrices are necessarily in a
very specific matrix algebra called the
bose-mesner algebra and what is nice
about this bosemaster algebra is that is
a diagonalizable algebra in other words
this means that it doesn't matter what
is the this matrix that lies on the
algebra you know exactly what are going
to be the eigen spaces of this matrix
so you can just look at what are the
eigenvalues on these eigenspaces this
means that this semi-definite constraint
turns into a linear constraint because
if you just take any vector on that
linear space and check whether its
corresponding eigenvalue is actually
non-negative or not so that that
transforms the sdp into an lp that's how
these two guys are equivalent
now building on this idea lohan actually
said well
there is a very nice hierarchy in convex
optimization that gives you better and
better upper bounds for independence
number of graphs which is called the
laser hierarchy or also known under the
name sum of squares
so
and our graph still has the same
symmetry so the laser hierarchy will
inherit these symmetries from the graph
so we could try to factor out these
symmetries and the nice thing about this
hierarchy is that at level l it really
is studying l point interactions and
there's more things that are nice about
this thing is that the
it's it's a hierarchy that's getting
better and better so the only
disadvantage is that you know just as in
the usual theta prime if you don't
factor out the symmetries the hierarchy
is pretty bad because the graph is
pretty bad it's already exponential size
but it turns out that after factoring
out these symmetries the at least in
constant levels of the hierarchy
there's only polynomially many uh
constraints that you need to put and
polynomially many variables so it
becomes a polynomial sized hierarchy so
it's a very good hierarchy to run
numerically to get
specific bonds
and another thing that is very nice is
that okay if you don't restrict to
constant levels and you would allow to
go arbitrarily
high
results from convex optimization say
that actually
this hierarchy eventually will see the
correct value they will see what is the
precise size
of the best
possible code
because the the hierarchy is known to be
complete by level two to the end in fact
even
earlier than this
the disadvantage is that when you factor
out these symmetries the same problem
that uh
the same problem that we had on on
shrivert three-point interaction and
four-point interaction happens here you
don't actually get this magic of the
bose master algebra and you still have
an sdp on your hands you don't have an
lp
so
our work is actually to address this
problem and what we're going to do is
we're going to produce a hierarchy of
linear programs
that is complete and that is very much
uh it looks very similar to the del
certi hierarchy so that we have some
hope of analyzing so if we only wanted
an lp hierarchy that's complete we could
just do something like surely adams
that's already there but rally adam's
still not that easy to analyze we want
something that looks like the dos rtop
because then
maybe we have some hope that uh
techniques similar to mrw and other
techniques that have appeared in the
literature to do the lp bound can be
applied to this new hierarchy
so that that is that is basically our
work uh i should also say as you expect
from the title of the stock there's a
small disadvantage to our hierarchy
which is it really only
it's really only going to work for
linear votes in the sense that you can
define the hierarchy for non-linear
codes but it will only be complete for
linear codes and we will see what i mean
by that
now
how do we go about defining this
hierarchy so first recall what what was
the auxiliary we want something similar
to that right so that the austrialp was
studying these two-point interactions
and it was relying on these macwillian's
inequalities which i didn't get into
much details but at this point it's it's
just enough to look at how how the
things look like
now for us we're going to try to to
study interaction between more points so
what we're going to do is we're going to
define the l configuration of a certain
tuple of words so we're not studying
interaction between l points or rather
the configuration keeps track of
information about l points
and what does it do
it says well it's it's some function
from uh subsets of one through l to the
natural numbers and when you evaluate it
at a certain set it gives you the
hemming weight of the the sum of the
corresponding code words so for example
if i evaluate it at
the set 137 what you have to do is you
take the first word plus the third word
plus the seventh word and you do the
hemming weight of the result and that's
the result of the function so what this
this this configuration is keeping track
of is all possible hanging weights of
all possible code words in the linear
span of this tuple that's what it's
keeping track of
and
uh
as you might expect
we are going to look at the
configuration profile of the code which
is just the count of these
configurations on our code so you look
at all possible pairs of l tuples in the
code
and you look at the configuration of
their difference so you do x1 minus y1
x2 minus y2 and so on that gives you an
l tuple you look at its configuration it
is some function so let's count how many
such top some how many such pairs of
tuples give you a configuration equal to
some g and that is the configuration
profile profile of the code for each g
it gives you this discount
and our hope is that we want to prove
some sort of higher order macros
inequality we're going to define some
crotchet polynomial that is indexed by
configurations and it's evaluated on
configurations and when you do this
linear combination
of this um configuration profile
as long as it comes from a code it's
always something that's non-negative
that's what we're hoping to prove
okay so but before we actually get into
details of what are these higher order
project polynomials let me just show you
how the hierarchy is going to look like
it's going to look like something very
similar to the usual dose rtlp
so you're going to maximize the sum of
all
the variables corresponding to all
possible configurations uh the
configuration the variable of the
configuration zero is required to be one
you have some forbidden set which i will
tell you in a second what it is and it's
going to be a negative and you're going
to have the macro inequalities and as
you would expect the intended solution
is this is this configuration profile of
the code and let's check again that most
of these inequalities are satisfied or
most of these constraints are satisfied
so a0 is equal to 1 is very easy because
only things of the form x x survive so
you get something like c to dl divided
by c to the r which is one
um it's certainly non-negative
quantities because they're counting
things uh there will be the macro lens
inequalities which we'll see in just a
moment and what about the forbidden set
well the forbidden set we have to think
about it for a second
so i take two tuples of code words in my
code and my code has distance at least
and then i take their difference right
now i have a tuple of both words
such that each of the code words is a
difference of two guys that are in my
code right well my code has distance at
least e so this means that each of each
of the code words in this resulting
tuple either is a zero code word or it
has hemi weight at least
which means that the corresponding
configuration
if i evaluate it at a singleton set
there is a set of primary one that
corresponds to evaluating only the
hemming weight of one of these guys and
these this timing weight either is zero
or more than d
so this means that whenever i see a
configuration that doesn't satisfy that
that means there is some singleton
coordinate with value between zero and d
then there should be a constraint that
says you know the count of these guys is
zero right because this is satisfied by
codes of distance at least so that is
the the forbidden constraint
now
before we proceed let us note that if if
the code is linear actually there's an
easier way of computing this uh
configuration profile instead of
counting these pairs of tuples of code
words you can just count the tuples in
the code that has configuration g and
you get the same quantity this is just a
change of variables in translation
and this is actually very useful because
for linear codes you can actually add
even more restrictions uh in fact for
linear codes
imagine that you would have a
configuration such that
some some coordinate of this
configuration indexed by some set that
is not necessarily a single tone
has a value between zero and b right
this means that if for a particular
linear code you're saying that well i'm
trying to find a couple of fold words
such that if i add a certain amount of
them i get something of hemingway
between zero strictly between zero and d
that is nonsense because my code is
linear so any kind of combination of
code words that i take in my linear code
is going to be a code word and because
it's a linear code it's required to have
hemi hemingway either zero or above or
equal to d right so in fact for linear
codes you can put this better set in
this in this restriction here and this
is going to be is going to make a huge
difference for the hierarchy using these
extra restrictions
okay
now let me tell you what are these
crotchet polynomials and the mcqueen's
inequalities and let's start with the
with the base case so so this is the
usual uh mcwilliams inequality so it was
this linear combination and the quantity
polynomial is this alternating sum of
products of binomials now for us it's
going to be more convenient to use a
different formula for this guy which is
this formula here
so what you do is you sum over all code
words of weight exactly i
the character of r y evaluated at any
code word that has weight j and it
doesn't matter which code word of way j
you you use you always get this quantity
so that that's that's kind of important
and our hope is to prove this lemma
right that's we have the analogous thing
but for l configurations and the higher
order quadrature polynomial is going to
be based off of this formula for the the
base case so what we're going to do is
we're going to say well if you want to
evaluate the h polynomial on g you sum
over all tuples of words that have
configuration h
the character of y evaluated at any
tuple of words that have
has configuration g
and of course at some point you need to
prove that it doesn't matter which tuple
you choose you always get the same
quantity uh and this is proven but i'm
not going to prove it here i would
rather actually prove this number
because the proof is actually very
simple very short i can even do it in a
single slide
so here's the proof so here i just
copied the the
definition of the project polynomial
just rewrote uh slightly by saying the
quantity polynomial evaluated the
configuration of a couple of words x is
just this sum of characters
well this sum of characters is
essentially doing a fourier transform
right there's a certain set and because
you're only summing over the set is just
the fourier transform of this uh of the
indicator of the set except for some
normalization factors that don't really
matter too much
so so that is a very simple observation
and we are interested in this quantity
here right you want to prove that this
is uh negative
so if you open up the definition of the
configuration profile you're going to
see that you get the sum
over
a pair of tuples of code words uh that
are required to be in the code and you
evaluate the crotchet and the
configuration of their difference now
if you do some very basic algebraic
manipulation you notice that this is
just the inner product between this this
this function and the convolution of the
indicator of the code to the l with
itself except for some leading uh
normalization factors now you apply
parseval and once you apply participle
uh
these things are free of transforms of
each other except for some normalization
factors so uh when you apply first of
all you get in the care of this
particular set of things that have
configuration h
times uh well the fourier transform of
this becomes the square of the fourier
transform of this right
so
now it's obviously not negative because
this is a square and this is a
non-negative function so it's obviously
no negative so that that concludes the
improvement so it's a very easy proof
and in fact this is just the it's the
same proof of the usual macronutrients
inequalities is just done in this higher
order level okay now before i proceed to
the the main results let me just point
out some other properties of these
cartridge polynomials so first we do
have an explicit formula that looks like
an alternating sum of now it's
multinomials is even more complicated so
it's this complicated formula which i'm
not going to get into details the only
thing that i want you to notice is that
if you use the previous formula you
would have a sum that would have to look
essentially at all possible tuples of
code words so it would take exponential
time this formula is much better because
at least if l is constant it's a
polynomial uh time formula because this
sum here is actually there's polynomial
many terms here assuming that l is
constant so that's what i want you to
get out of this explicit form
now
just as the usual project polynomials
there are some orthogonality relations
for these higher order project
polynomials there are some reflection
relations for these higher order things
and there are also also some recursive
relations there there are some
recurrence relations that they satisfy
which i'm not going to get into details
and the reason why all of these hold is
because actually
if you know a little bit about the
association scheme theory the crotchet
polynomials are what are called q
functions of the heming scheme and this
higher order quadrature polynomials they
are also the q functions of a different
association scheme that whose base set
is is this larger
cube uh that that has this cube of l
tuples of n cold works
and
if you don't know what's association
schemes uh
don't worry too much what i want you to
to get out of this is that that result
that i mentioned before from shriver
that the dosartop was equivalent to the
theta prime
this is actually true for general
association scheme so this is also going
to be true for us so there will be a
particular graph that you can define
which you can even guess what it is it's
not that hard
such that r lp is actually equivalent to
the theta prime of this of this graph
and it's going to be important for us
and you know you're factoring out some
symmetries here
okay so let me now state the main
results uh and as you might expect from
the title of the talk
the first main result is that this
hierarchy is complete
so here this theorem is just saying that
it's approximately complete
in the following sense if i give you
some precision epsilon and you look at a
level that is you know roughly n squared
and some some other factors based on the
precision
then well we already know that uh if you
take the lf root of this hierarchy you
get
an upper bound for the linear codes now
this theorem is saying in fact this
upper bound is quite good it's only far
away but by a very small multiplicative
factor from the true value of the
optimal code
now let us also notice that you know
being far away very very small value is
actually good enough because we know
that the the true value is going to be
an integer so if the precision is
sufficiently small you can say okay it's
something between
10 million and 10 million point five
then it needs to be 10 million and in
fact
in our case
you're looking at linear code so so in
fact you know that is going to be a
power of two so even this example is not
even a good example
now
as i said uh this is this is true for
linear quotes when you add those extra
restrictions if you don't add those
extra restrictions uh actually the
hierarchy is pretty bad it completely
collapses you can prove that
if you're doing the non-linear version
of this where you keep the base
restrictions then the optimum value
stays the same it doesn't matter how
high of a level you go it has exactly
the same optimum value
now i will not get into details about
this collapse theorem even because the
other theorem is much more interesting i
will give you some very vague sketch of
of how do you prove this approximate
completeness so so here is the sketch
so first
remember that as i said there is some
association scheme uh going on in the
background and shriver says
the lp is equivalent to the theta prime
of the corresponding graph and the
corresponding graph here is the graph
over l tuples of code words such that
you put an edge every time
the configuration of the difference is
in the forbidden set for the linear
codes
now
now we need to get into a little bit
more of details of this theta prime
function uh we want to prove that this
the the optimum value of this is at most
uh
you know the
size of the best possible call to the l
so first remember it has a lot of
symmetry so without loss of generality
we can factor out these symmetries and
consider only symmetric solutions for us
here you can only you you don't even
need to factor all the symmetries you
could just factor the translation
symmetries which is what is important is
that uh once you factor the symmetries
um
this condition that says trace is equal
to one
forces all the diagonal entries to be
exactly equal to two to the minus ml
and then because it's going to be a psd
matrix uh just by looking at two by two
minors that the determinant needs to be
non-negative so all other entries in
absolute value can only be at most two
to the minus n l so that these are some
very trivial observations
another very easy observation is that
this condition of saying the
configuration of the difference is a
forbidden thing so when you have an edge
this is equivalent to saying that the
linear span of the difference of these
tuples
gives you a code of distance that is
less than b a non-trivial code that is
of distance of that is less than d
that is the equivalence so what we're
going to do is we're going to count
how many pairs
are such that their span have dimension
the the span of their difference
have dimension k
and here we only need a very trivial
upper bound so because i'm counting
these pairs with the difference i can
just say well
take 2 to the n l choices of x and just
choose y right accordingly so you just
choose the difference and then choose x
appropriately so that gives you a
leading factor of 2 to the n l and for
the difference you need the difference
just to to be an l tuple that spans
something that has dimension k so you
can just think that you know out of the
l positions k of them will spend the
space and all the others need to be a
linear combination of them so this is a
very trivial upper bound because out of
the outpositions you choose k on those k
positions you essentially can have any
vector and on the other l minus k
positions you need to have a combination
of the
the k vectors that you picked before
so this is a very trivial problem
now we are particularly interested in
comparing this with the
best possible code so if you let k0 be
the dimension of the best possible code
then the objective value of this is
going to be at most the l infinity norm
times the number of non-zero entries of
this matrix well for for a matrix entry
to be non-zero
it cannot be such that you know the span
of the difference has dimension larger
than k 0 because k 0 is the maximum
possible dimension of a valid code so
you just sum all of these n k's from 0
to k 0 and our choice of level is such
that when you do the calculations you
get something that looks like one plus
epsilon to the l times two to the k zero
l so when you extract l of root uh
you're gonna get the the
the result
now before i conclude uh with some
future work on open questions let me
just notice that this proof um
really did not use much about distance
right it was just manipulating the fact
that the code is linear and the
dimension of the best possible code and
in fact this is not really crucial you
can use the same proof to to show that
uh to to apply this to other
restrictions that are not distance being
at least d you can do things like
epsilon balance calls you can do things
like i only allow a certain
a certain subset of distances to appear
and in fact any kind of restriction that
is of the form you look at all possible
tuples in your code and you require
their configurations to be
exactly in a certain set
these are all restrictions
that that give you a hierarchy that is
complete for linear codes
another thing you might have noticed is
that uh there's nothing nothing really
much special about the binary case
in fact you can do this over any finite
field you just need to be slightly
careful because over a finite field you
can either count on zero entries or you
can count symbol occurrences it turns
out that both of them work you just need
to you know do it twice uh slightly
carefully
uh and in fact uh if you don't care too
much about completeness and you only
care about defining a hierarchy you can
do this in an even more general setting
uh of translation schemes over left arm
modules
under very mild assumptions but i'm not
going to get too much into details i'm
just going to give you a very simple
example which is you can even do hamming
skiing over more general things that are
not fields
but i'm not going to get into details
here now
let me finish with future work and some
open problems so first uh it's not
exactly in the paper that we submitted
here but uh we now know that the
hierarchy is actually complete by level
n it's a
considerably more complicated proof uh
but it is actually complete by level n
and here it's actually complete is not
even approximately complete you it
actually finds the precise value of the
best code
uh and the vague idea behind it is that
there are when you go to higher levels
you have more symmetries than just the
translation symmetries and the
permutation symmetries you also have the
action of the general in your group so
if you factor the general linear group
along with the translation symmetries
you land on the whole set of subspaces
of this finite vector space and you can
explore mobius inversion to to do some
tricks there and actually get
completeness by level n
now let me just uh finish with a couple
of questions so first
the question that actually motivated
this work is
can we use this to improve the
the lp boundary symbolically right and
can we analyze this this this hierarchy
right because a priori if we could
analyze it by saying level n we would
know the the the precise size of the
code
and if you if you're thinking about how
did mrrw came up with their lp bound
you could try to do the same kind of
thing here you can hook up the you can
just compute what is the dual program
and you can try to cook up a very good
dual solution and if it's very good then
it's going to give you a very good
bounce and so cooking up these explicit
dual solutions uh is a very very natural
problem to work on
now
as i mentioned uh this hierarchy is not
good at all for non-linear codes in fact
it completely collapses so a very
natural question is can you come up with
a structured lp hierarchy that also
works for nonlinear codes and is also
complete right
a different kind of question is well
when you come up with these all these
convex optimization bonds uh
one thing that
sometimes you do is you run this on the
on the computer to see what kinds of
bonds do you get out of that but these
ones even though they do provide some
evidence they're not very good because
they're they're run for a fixed n right
so a very very natural question a more
abstract but still natural question is
can you come up with some sort of limit
program a limit convex optimization
problem
such that you only input the relative
distance and it gives you an upper bound
for for the the asymptotic rate rather
than just the rate at the fixed to level
end
and finally uh as i mentioned this this
hierarchy can be constructed for general
translation schemes but we don't know
how to construct it for general
association schemes and the reason why
this would be interesting is because the
the lp bond that i have been discussing
here is actually what's called the first
lp bound of mrrw in the same paper they
also have a second one now the first one
is based off of the hemisphere the dosat
of the heming scheme which is a
translation scheme but the second one is
based off of the johnson scheme which is
not a translation string so the question
is
if you have something that looks like
the johnson scheme can you also produce
a hierarchy on top of that that is a
complete maybe it's complete for
linear calls whatever that means
and that is a very that's an abstract
question but it's still a very
interesting question
so
that's all that i had to say thank you
all for listening and
this is a very simple summary slide if
you want you can pause the video here to
take a look
thank you